PROFESSOR: Good morning.
Today's lecture will
deal with Zeeman effect.
And then we'll get started with
a semi-classical approximation.
So Zeeman in effect
is the last topic
we do with respect
to the hydrogen
atom and the corrections
of perturbation theory
and with WKB or the
semi-classical approximation,
we begin a new chapter in 806.
Zeeman effect.
So this is an
effect having to do
with an atom in
a magnetic field.
It was discovered by a Dutch
physicist, Peter Zeeman,
who lived from 1865 to
1943, who was a Dutch.
The work was
actually done in 1896
at a time where there was
very little idea of quantum
mechanics to be, and
he got a Nobel Prize
for in the year 1902.
So what he discovered
was the spectral lines
seemed to split in the
presence of a magnetic field.
It's an old result,
therefore, 100 years old.
Its explanation
and understanding
took about a couple of decades,
because you couldn't do it
without quantum mechanics.
So nobody could
quite figure out what
had happened, but was very,
very important in its time.
It still remains very important.
People use the Zeeman
effect all the time.
In fact, it's used
nowadays in studies
of astrophysics, studies
of the sun, the sunspots.
You know, there are
places in the sun,
where the temperature
is a little lower,
and that's places where the
magnetic field lines in the sun
sort of breakout from the
interior to the exterior.
And it's interesting,
because the sun produces
this cycle of
solar spots, and it
happens, because the sun
doesn't rotate uniformly,
has a different rotation
speed in the equator,
faster than in the poles, so
the magnetic field lines that
go from north to south in
the sun get tangled up,
and they start breaking up
and doing all these things.
So people want to know
what is the magnetic field
in the solar sunspot.
And in fact, they observe
the weak magnetic fields away
from the solar
sunspots, and then they
see the spectrum of an atom.
And suddenly, as you move
inside the spot, the field,
the spectrum, the lines split.
And they can measure
the magnetic fields
very accurately.
They're of the order of 3,000
Gauss, 2,000, 3,000 Gauss.
And it's pretty
interesting work.
So this Zeeman effect
remains very important.
So what is the Zeeman effect?
We have Zeeman effect here.
We have the magnetic field
interacting with the electron,
and the electron now has
two magnetic moments,
a magnetic moment associated
with the orbital motion.
This looks completely
like the classical formula
of the magnetic moment due to a
particle that goes in circles.
It produces a current,
and that current
is proportional to the angular
momentum of the rotating
particle.
And of course, there
is the magnetic moment
due to the spin that
has a factor of 2 here.
This g factor, we've
discussed before.
S.
So H Zeeman, you put an
external magnetic field
into the atom, a constant
uniform external magnetic
field, and you have
a minus mu dot b,
so you have a interaction
mu l plus mu s,
dot B. So this is e over 2mc.
That's the typical factor here,
and a recognizable l plus 2s.
So it's not l plus s.
It's l plus 2s times b.
And many times, we think
of B, align the axis
so that it is in
the z direction.
So this turns out to be e
over 2mc lz plus 2sz times
B. So this is the
Zeeman Hamiltonian.
But this is part of
a story of an atom.
So if we want to think of
the hydrogen atom properly,
we must consider and reconsider
what was the Hamiltonian there.
And we had an H for
the hydrogen atom.
That was an H 0.
That was the familiar
one, p squared
over 2m minus e squared over r.
Then we had a fine
structure Hamiltonian,
delta H, fine structure.
Let's put fs for fine structure.
Those were the relativistic
terms, the Darwin term,
and the spin orbit coupling.
The three of them
constituted what we call
defined structure Hamiltonian.
And now we have a Zeeman effect.
I probably should
go delta H Zeeman,
because it's an addition here
to the term we had before.
It refers to what I
call just H Zeeman.
But in the context
of the hydrogen atom,
we should call it
delta H Zeeman.
And now, we have to rethink.
And the reason the Zeeman
effect is non-trivial for us,
and it's a very interesting and
somewhat challenging example
of what we have to do
in perturbation theory,
is that we cannot forget
about the fine structure.
So if it would be just this,
it would be kind of simple.
But we have the whole thing.
So we have to make an
approximation sometimes.
And we're going to consider
two interesting cases,
the very weak Zeeman effect and
the very strong Zeeman effect.
I will not consider the
intermediate Zeeman effect,
not because it's
not interesting,
but because there's very little
you can do to simplify it,
and to think about it.
You basically have to
go ahead and diagonalize
the large matrix.
So while it's important, and
if your life depended on this,
and your research dependent
on this, you would do it.
For us, we have a lot to
learn from the weak case
and the strong case,
lots of concepts,
and we'll leave the
intermediate one for later.
So how can we decide how
to treat these terms?
Well, we should look
physically at what's happening.
We have a magnetic field,
an external magnetic field.
But the fine structure
constant taught you
that there is something like
an internal magnetic field
in the atom.
It's that magnetic field
responsible for spin orbit
coupling is that magnetic field
that the electron sees when
it's going around the proton.
There's a static electric field,
but whenever you are in motion,
a static electric
field in the lab
also has a magnetic
field by relativity,
and you do see a magnetic field.
You could also imagine it
as you are the electron,
and the problem is
going around you,
and creates at the center of
the loop, a magnetic field.
In any case, you've looked
at that magnetic field.
And we can call it the
internal magnetic field
due to spin orbit.
As one exercise in
the homework, you've
been asked to estimate the
value of that internal magnetic
field.
Is it a Gauss, 1,000
Gauss, 10,000 Gauss?
How much it is for
a typical level?
So there's a number
here that this interest.
And now we can decide
whether we have a weak Zeeman
effect or a strong
Zeeman effect,
by looking how your external
magnetic field compares
with this little magnetic field.
So we'll have a weak
Zeeman effect, A. Zeeman.
When B is much smaller
than B internal.
And therefore, the
effects of Zeeman
is going to be smaller
than fine structure.
So really, when you
look at this line,
and you have the
first two terms,
you should think
of these two terms
as your new known Hamiltonian.
And the Zeeman term,
at its perturbation.
Yes.
You've solved for
the fine structure
coupling and the shift.
So this is the known thing.
These are going to be the known
states with known energies.
You only know them the first
order, but you know them.
And then the Zeeman
effect will be
a perturbation theory on this.
This is the weak Zeeman effect.
How about the strong
Zeeman effect?
So B will be strong Zeeman.
This time, the magnetic
field associated
with the Zeeman effect, the
external magnetic field,
is much smaller than
the magnetic field
responsible for
spin orbit coupling.
And this time, what
are we going to do?
Well, we will take
the Hamiltonian.
It will be H 0.
The strong Zeeman effect
means this Zeeman Hamiltonian
is a lot more important than
the spin orbit coupling.
So we'll add delta
H Zeeman here.
And we hope this will be
our known Hamiltonian,
because anyway, the Zeeman
stuff is much stronger now
than fine structure.
So this should be
our non-Hamiltonian.
You should complain,
no, this is not known.
I haven't done Zeeman,
but we'll look at it.
And once we have our
known Hamiltonian here,
spin orbit has to be rethought.
Fine structure has to be
rethought as a perturbation.